this morning George Osborne stepped out
of this building behind me to deliver
his fourth budgets now like all budgets
it was an attempt at magic to say he's
giving away lots of money in tax cuts
he's raising lots of revenue growth is
going fantastically well and his
centerpiece was a massive tax cut for
pensioners which he reckons will net him
more than a billion quid a year so is it
too good to be true when what tricks has
he used to conjure up his budget today
listen below this story was a simple one
and economic recovery and not just any
old recovery he told us but we are now
growing faster than Germany faster than
Japan faster than the United States so
is it true if you take the growth at the
end of last year then yes that's just if
you count the g7 and crucially if you
take this year alone any country can
grow a lot and one year low and is
outpacing us right now but George
Osborne's problem is that this economic
recovery comes after years of pretty
slow to no growth so on a per capita
basis it's not particularly impressive
so yes we're growing quickly but even
now we're a midway through the worst
recovery in history the crashes in the
90s the 80s and even the 1930s we're
short to live than this one but today's
figures show that on a per capita basis
it's going to be about 20 17 until we
get back to where we were in 2008 that
is for Britain a lost decade so what's
powering the recovery now skeptics might
argue that's one thing alone the debt
when you can go down to the bank and
borrow with less than the rate of
inflation it looks like a pretty crazy
system but Britain isn't really
recovering from his debt party yes a lot
of debt was run up in belabor years it
went from a low of 310 billion to 504
billion but today's budget show that the
national debt will hit 1.4 trillion by
2017-18 this means that Osborne will
have increased debt more in five years
than labor will
done in 13 it means his debt targets
will not be hit and the cheap rates now
mean that banks are falling over
themselves to lend us cheap cash but is
this recovery being driven by the debt
well look at this chart it shows
economic growth and credit growth this
and this is the sign of credit fuel
growth this not so much so these figures
from Citibank suggest that Osborne does
have reason to believe that even though
he is borrowing like a drunken Keynesian
his recovery is not a debt-fuelled
illusion of course our Chancellor does
like a bit of cheap debt he today
elaborated on his help to buy promise
where he'll lend money to homebuyers
help fueling already raging housing
market it's been extended to 2020 which
makes economists nervous this is what he
had to say we're extending the help to
buy equity loan scheme for the rest of
the decade so we get a hundred and
twenty thousand new homes belt in other
words a politician wants to help us out
by intervening in the housing markets
now where have we heard that before this
will use money taxpayers money to help a
qualified low-income buyer make a down
payment so George Osborne's policy is
just a little bit of subprime lending
after all what could possibly go wrong
but in today's budget there was a
serious piece of economic good news and
that's the jobs when he took office with
these forecasts that now look so rosy he
imagined there will be 30 million people
who work by the general election that
was some burst given that he planned to
cut 1.3 million public sector jobs his
idea at the time was written off by
eight balls as sheer fantasy met balls
was right as things turned out there are
no likely to be 30 point six million
jobs by the next election better than
the rosy forecast and unlike for labor
years the majority of the jobs growth is
now being accounted for by uk-born
workers more than five years after
Gordon Brown came out with a sound bite
were finally seeing British jobs for
British workers so let's look a bit more
what's gone so badly right George
Osborne glossed over it's in the budget
he was so keen to get to his penchant
finale but somebody from a Treasury told
me a few weeks ago even they don't seem
to know what's going so right in the
jobs market that's funny because other
people do the Bank of England not so
long ago identified benefit sanctions in
Duncan Smith's welfare crack down as one
of the reasons why British people are
now more inclined to look for work and
stay on the welfare that it's more
difficult to get your hands on and then
there is immigration Theresa May is
crack down on the non EU immigrants and
look at this chart you can see a strange
divergence of a number of EU immigrants
finding work and the non EU immigrants
who don't seem to might that be related
to the Home Office's crackdown on non EU
immigrants and let's not forget real
wages they are not keeping pace with
inflation look at this perhaps the worst
graph in the whole budget it shows real
earnings are not recovering to their
2008 peak in fact they're not likely to
do so for years to come this is for
people who are on salaries which is the
vast majority of us 13 or maybe 15 years
of hurt is going to be a long time
before the average worker manages to get
is earning power restored but the
pensions thing is without doubt the
cornerstone off today them we don't have
any graphs for that because this has
until now been off the economic radar
people haven't really thought what would
happen if you let people use their
pension funds as a massive bank account
except George Osborne has he is
calculated that is going to raise lots
of money is going to raise him 320
million quids next year 600 the year
after nine hundred and ten million quid
the year after that and finally 1.2
billion quid in 2018-19 mrs. a tax cut
which is netting in the Treasury money
because treasure Lee believes the
pensioners will spend spend spend as
they work at what they want to buy they
may be more inclined to vote Tory but
what is the cost of all
the reason why we've gots limits on
pension pots is to stop people running
them down and relying on the state in
later years will this happen we don't
know how is George Osborne certain that
won't happen he isn't it's a gamble but
a gamble which places faith in the
ability of pensioners to manage their
own pensions and those who aren't
pensioners to make proper planning
usually Chancellor's who bets on giving
people more freedom do tend to win but
for George Osborne this could be the
biggest gamble of his career all told
this was as you might expect an
electioneering budget from George
Osborne he's come up with something even
Gordon Brown didn't think of get more
money from pensioners by giving them
more access to their pensions the public
finances are not that great shape but
he's hoping that the voters
disproportionate number of whom are
pensioners will be too busy shopping to
care